i love this next story because
i've been speaking out against
anti-semitic louis farrakhan
for a very long time if you don't know
who louis farrakhan is
i'm jealous of you first first of all i
should say but i'm going to tell you
anyway
he's a black nationalist he's the leader
of the nation of islam
which is a southern poverty law center
tracked
hate group it's a black supremacist
anti-semitic
group unfortunately there are
people on the left who like louis
farrakhan and in fact i did a story
back in march of this year explaining
that there's this coziness in admiration
from some of the leaders of the women's
march uh
with and of louis farrakhan which is
exactly what the left needs to get away
from
needs to run away from as fast as they
can possibly run
because it's truly and really toxic
so cut to yesterday when donald trump jr
tweets an article
about louis farrakhan showing up in iran
and chanting death to america and he
asks in his tweet
when will the democrats disavow this guy
answer never this is particularly
hilarious
because louis farrakhan is a trump
supporter
back in 2016 i did a story about louis
farrakhan
who praised donald trump for quote
standing up to
the jewish community whatever that means
and this is why it's so important to
understand
it doesn't matter if trump's personally
anti-semitic
it doesn't matter if trump's personally
a white supremacist
if the white supremacists see trump as
their guy
then that is all they need in this case
an anti-semitic black supremacist louis
farrakhan
identified that trump was signaling
the way he liked i guess on issues of
whatever it means to stand up to the
jewish community here's another clip of
farrakhan
from just months ago talking about how
good trump is well that wasn't the
intent
of this administration to do a lot of
good for us
but the nature of this administration
is good for us because now
you know sometimes you think your way
you are not
and so trump is letting you know
where you really stand and because of
trump's
way he is an anomaly there's never been
no president quite like mr trump
but there's something that he's doing
i'm gonna come out
in a few weeks and talk about it but
trump
is destroying every enemy
that was an enemy of our rise
yeah so i'm going to remind you
that donald trump jr is saying the
problem is that
democrats won't disavow louis
farrakhan uh i agree with trump jr
democrats should disavow louis farrakhan
if it comes up
although he's not really that involved
with democrats anyway
although his connection to the women's
march leaders is very concerning
but he's on the record as a trump
supporter
dating all the way back to 2016 and to
go further
there are prominent right wingers who
have celebrated
farrakhan's praise of trump it's more
projection from the right remember our
favorite
new politically awakened right winger
candace owens she tweeted a few months
ago but has since deleted the tweet as
she often does i guess this one
wasn't a good wasn't a good idea to
tweet this she said quote in no way do i
endorse farrakhan's views
but holy crap this is a really big deal
he has just aligned himself with the
trump administration
what is going on in the black community
right now is unprecedented flag this
it's relevant and then glenn beck agreed
tweeting this
is huge candace owens is correct and it
is the principle
of what caused all of our damage in the
middle east it never leads to peace the
enemy of my enemy is my friend
we must find reconciliation in our
hearts
why isn't pat donald trump jr concerned
that farrakhan likes his dad
and that fellow right wingers have
celebrated that praise because
it's getting black people off the
plantation
as they like to say i don't get it but
he seems to just not have the facts
i just think it's ignorance i don't
think that donald trump jr has seen the
update now that louis farrakhan supports
trump
and you pointed out candace owens and
glenn beck there i think
most people on the right are against
farrakhan and in fact
they've used him as a way to argue
against identity politics because
they made it seem as if the left
supports farrakhan
even though he's in anti-semite because
he's black
because he's a muslim and apparently
those two things
rank higher than uh jews in the
oppression hierarchy
but that's that you know maybe you could
you would see that could have some merit
right
as a way to argue against identity
politics but it completely falls apart
once you find out that fair con is now
apparently a trump supporter
everything is backwards i mean they
literally say the opposite of what is
true on
issue after issue after issue and that's
exactly why we have to vote them out and
we're actually doing something so
uh producer max posted to
the david pakman show instagram account
today at david pakman show
a picture of pat behind the scenes with
his gigantic oversized
comically enormous i voted sticker and
we're encouraging people to post your
own
i voted images and tag at david pakman
show
on instagram tell us what issue got you
out to the polls today and while you're
on instagram and following the show
follow me as well i'm on there as david
dot
pakman today's program is sponsored in
part
by blinkist.com slash pacman if you've
not already heard about blinkist
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take non-fiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction
they condense the book into a 15-minute
audio book you get all the most
important information
and insights from each book but you can
soak up the entire essence of the book
in one sitting
i've listened to a ton of books on
blinkist one
recent one is robert reich's new book
the common good
also bunk by kevin young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo science
miniseries that we're producing
and if you are a david pakman show
viewer or listener you can get a seven
day free trial
by going to blinkist.com pacman if
you're watching on youtube
use the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get
uh the full access to thousands
of condensed audio books for about five
bucks a month
that's b l i n k i s t
dot com forward slash p a k
m a n